Transcriber: Amira Mones
المدقّق: Fatima Alwalidi
حل الظلام على كل المكان.
ظلام مفاجىء.
ظلام مخيف.
لا يرى أي شيء.
ظلام
لا نرى
ملامح الموجودين.
ظلام
لا نرى
الناس المحيطين بنا.
ظلام
لا نرى أي شيء في القاعة.
متى سيعود النور؟
ومتى ستعود الحياة؟
ما هي شعوركم في هذه اللحظات؟
خوف؟
قلق؟
توتر؟
أريد أن أشرب الماء؟
لا، سأنتظر إلى أن تشعل الإضاءة.
أريد أن أكمل قهوتي؟
لا، سأنتظر إلى أن تعود الإضاءة.
فما بالكم
بكفيفة
عاشت سنوات طويلة
داخل هذا الظلام.
من منصة المتحدثين الملهمين
كوثر الحمدي ترحب بكم، فأهلًا وسهلًا.
(تصفيق)
خريجة علم الاجتماع والخدمة الاجتماعية من
جامعة الملك فيصل لعام 2018
صاحبة مبادرة برايل بوك
وحاصلة على جائزة ثمر
من بنك التنمية الاجتماعية.
(تصفيق)
بداية حياتي ما كانت في أي مشكلة صحية.
ضعف نظر بسيط،
عولج بلباس النظارة.
بدأت دراسة السنة الأولى
إلى أن أنهيت السنة الثانية في المدرسة
من غير أي مشاكل.
فجأة،
وبدون مقدمات،
وبدون أي سابق إنذار،
انفصال مفاجئ للشبكية.
تلاشى البصر
شيئًا فشيئًا.
إلى أن.... لا نرى أي شيء.
كانت الصدمة مفاجئة على الأهل.
صدمة مرعبة.
صدمة مخيفة.
كوثر وقفت حياتها.
كوثر ما تقدر تكمل دراسة.
كوثر ما راح تعيش مثل ما يعيش
الأطفال الذين مثلها بالسن.
إلى أن
أخبر أهلي بأن هناك مدرسة
خاصة لتدريس المكفوفين.
تم تسجيلي فيها.
مديرة المدرسة قالت
هناك خيارين:
إما أن كوثر ترجع
وتعيد السنتين التي درستهم،
أو تكمل من السنة التي هي وقفت عندها
ولكن راح تكون صعوبات.
إذا رجعت سنة أولى، راح تتعلم
كيف تلمس،
كيف تمسك،
كيف تشوف كل شيء باللمس
وتتقوى عندها اللمس.
أما إذا دخلت مباشرة بالدراسة العلمية
قد تجد صعوبات في تعلم برايل.
متخيلين واحدة أخذت المرتبة الأولى
تعيد سنتين؟
أخذت امتياز، تعيد سنتين؟
وين صارت هذه؟ في أي مكان؟
هذه لحظة أثرت فيني إلى الآن.
تخرجت من الثانوي،
قلت يا كوثر المفروض انت متخرجة قبل سنتين.
تخرجت من الجامعة،
قلت يا كوثر اللي مثلك تخرجوا
من سنتين
وهم توظفوا،
وانت توش تتخرجين؟
هذهِ اللحظة،
لما تكون في القمة، تكون أعلى القمة
وفجأة إلى الهاوية، سقوط مفاجئ،
راح تحس بقوة الضربة التي وصلتك
على ما تستوعب الألم،
تستوعب الضربة اللي وصلتك
راح تبدأ تصعد السلم خطوة خطوة.
ولكن هذه اللحظات
خطواتك راح تكون ثابتة.
راح تكون قوية.
في كلها ثقة.
من غير خوف، من غير أي تردد.
هذه الصعوبة
راح تجعلك ناجح ومتميز.
دخلت الجامعة
واجهتني صعوبات
هنا بدأت المرحلة الثانية وصعوبات أخرى.
أول من أهم الصعوبات التي أنا تحملتها
وكل كفيف يدخل الجامعة يتحملها
هي تحويل الكتب إلى برايل
أنني أنا آخذ هذا الكتاب، وبنفسي
أكتبه كلمة كلمة
أحوله للWord
عشان بس أقدر أطبعه باللمس
ووقت الاختبار أجي أذاكر.
كانت بعض الحلول هناك بين المكفوفين
أنا وزميلتي كنا نفس التخصص
فوجدنا حل مؤقت
أنتِ نص المادة أو أنتِ نص المواد وأنا النص
أنتِ تكتبن مادة مادتين ثلاث،
أنا أكتب النص الثاني.
وبعدها بنروح لمطبعة برايل بالجامعة ونطبع.
هذا حل مؤقت
كل كفيف ممكن أن هو يعمل في الجامعة.
سألت نفسي
يا كوثر
الآن قاربت التخرج
وأنهيت كل هذه الصعوبات
وقدرت تتغلبين عليها
ما راح يجي مكفوفين من بعدك
يعانون نفس الصعوبة؟
ما راح يجي مكفوفين يشوفون
نفس الصعوبات، يحاولون يتغلبون عليها؟
لماذا لا تطلقين مبادرة تخفف من حملهم؟
تخفف من هذا التعب
اللي الطالب يجلس يكتب يكتب
عشان بس قبل الاختبار بيوم بيومين يذاكر
وتكون كل حياته الدراسية كتابة بكتابة
وتحويل المادة إلى برايل.
فأطلقت مبادرة برايل بوك.
طبعا هذه المبادرة
(تصفيق)
هذه المبادرة فكرتها أن الشخص السليم يتطوع
أنه يكتب ويحول المادة الدراسية للكفيف
إلى الWord
عشان بعدين يقدر يطبعها بالبرايل.
طرحت الفكرة، سويت إعلان واتساب:
في مبادرة كذا كذا، من يريد يشارك؟
فكرت قلت: إذا عشر متطوعات، عشرين متطوعة
شاركوا معي، جدًا ممتاز.
أول الشهور، شهر، شهرين، تفاجأت
خمسين متطوعة خلال أول الأيام
تطوعوا بالدخول هذه المبادرة
أنا أبي أشارك، أنا أبي..
(تصفيق)
منهم من قال: كنت أبحث عن مبادرة مميزة
أشارك فيها، أتطوع فيها
منهم من قال: شفت مكفوفين
معاي بالفصل الدراسي
شفت مكفوفين معاي بالقاعة
كيف هم قاعدين يتحملون صعوبات
الطالب سليم العادي لم يكن يتحملها
كان هو اللي يكتب.
فقلت أنا أبي أساعد هذه الفئة
اشتركوا معاي.
الفكرة نفسها سوقت لنفسها.
أنا ما دخلت إعلام
ولا تواصلت مع أي شخصية إعلامية.
إن انشري هذهِ فكرتي.
الفكرة نفسها سوقت لنفسها.
بعد فترة لقيت من المجتمع الاهتمام
لقيت من المجتمع الدعم
يا كوثر هذه طابعة برايل،
طابعة شخصية، خليها عندك بالبيت،
تطبعين لكل شخص كفيف يحتاج إلى الطباعة.
(تصفيق)
الآن في عام 2022
في واحدة من الطالبات طبعت عندي
من أول ما أطلقت المبادرة إلى أن تخرجت.
قالت لي كوثر هذي آخر مادة أنا أطبعها عندك
باركي لي راح أتخرج.
(تصفيق)
قلت معقول أربع سنوات راحت
أربع سنوات منذ انطلقت المبادرة.
هناك من استفاد وبدأ حياته الدراسية معاي
وأنهاها وتخرج مع هذه المبادرة.
وجاءوا أيضًا أشخاص آخرين
دخلوا واستفادوا من هذه المبادرة.
(تصفيق)
الآن أنا أقول لكل شخص موجود
في هذه القاعة
بادر.
لا تنتظر غيرك يبادر.
لا تخاف.
لا تتردد.
المبادرة في كل مكان
تقدر تسويها،
الأفكار موجودة.
لكن مين اللي يبادر؟
بادر على مستوى أسرتك، على
مستوى عائلتك، على مستوى القرية
بادر حتى لو على مستواك الشخصي.
أنت بادر لنفسك
ولا تنتظر غيرك يبادر.
شكرًا لحسن استماعكم.
السلام عليكم.
(تصفيق)